[Music]
the best performance by an actor in a
supporting role the nominees are George
Burns in the sunshine boys and One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest
we're just Meredith in the day of the
locust this Cerdan and Dog Day Afternoon
[Applause]
in shampoo
and the winner is hurry up swear I have
sinking spencey George Burns
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
let go thank you thank you very much
this is this is a beautiful moment for
me you know I've been I've been the show
business all of my life and I've loved
every minute of it and being honored
tonight by getting this award proves one
thing that if you stay in the business
long enough and if you can get to be old
enough you got to be new again
[Applause]
I was I was very fortunate to work with
two fine actors like Walter Matthau and
dick Benjamin and to be directed by her
boss and the script by Neil Simon and
we're a great producer like ray stock
and for a beautiful studio like MGM and
being surrounded by all that talent was
a great break for a newcomer like myself
and the last picture I made was 37 years
ago and making the sunshine boys was so
exciting I decided that I'm going to
make a picture every 37 years
you